These two points are inside the circle, this point is on the circle and this
point is outside the circle. Great work if you got all four of them correct.
Now if you weren't sure where to start, let's look at this first point and see
why it's on the circle. Then you might be able to figure out why these are
inside and this one's outside. Remember that this is really just a right
triangle in space. It has some horizontal distance x and some vertical distance
y. So we want to be sure that when we plug in the values for x like negative 6
and the value of y like positive 8, we get 100. So squaring negative 6 and
squaring 8 we'll get 36 plus 64 which equals 100. So yes, it turns out that
this statement is true. This means that the point negative 6, 8 Is a point on
our circle, since it satisfies the equation. We also know that this point is on
our circle since we can set up a right triangle. The point, negative 6, 8 is 6
units left from the origin and 8 units up. If we use the Pythagorean theorem
here, we'll discover that this side, or this radius, is 10. This should also
make sense because we really have a 3, 4, 5 triangle. The triangle has just
been multiplied by 2 to give us a 6, 8, 10 triangle. So we know that the
distance from the origin to this point is 10 units. And that matches with our
idea that any point on our circle is 10 units from the center. So, by checking
the point in our calculations or by drawing out a diagram, we can know that
this point is definitely on our circle. For this point, it turns out it will be
inside. When we check the point negative 9, 4, we'll plug in x with the value
of negative 9, and we'll substitute the value of y with 4. Simple, find the
left-hand side of our equation we'll get 97. We know that's not equal to 100,
and in fact this is less than 100. Since negative 9 squared plus 4 squared
equals 97, we really know that we're inside the circle. Remember that 10 is the
radius of our circle, it's the square root of this number. So, this means the
distance from the origin to this point is the square root of 97 which is
definitely less than 10. The right triangle for this point would look like this
we'd have 9 units to the left of the origin and then 4 units up. This point
would just be shy of reaching our circle. We know that the distance from the
origin to this point is the square root of 97. It's the square root of this
number. We really want this distance to be 10 or the square root of a 100 and
its not, its less than that. So that's how we know that this point is inside
the circle. The same would be true for the point 7, negative 7. If we plug in x
with the value of 7 and y with a value of negative 7 we'll get the statement 98
equals 100. This isn't true so we know that the distance from the origin to
this point is less than 10. So this point must be inside. And finally for this
point when we plug in x with a value of 5. And y with the value of 9, will get
106 equal to 100. This isn't true and we know that 106 is greater than 100,
that means that the distance of 5, 9, from the origin, is greater than 10. The
point, 5, 9 would be, just outside of our circle. We can even see this one
desmos. Here's the equation of our circle and we can see that the point
negative 6, 8 is on it. Even if we zoom in, we can quickly see that, yes, the
point is on the circle. And then this other point negative 9, 4 isn't. It's
just slightly inside of our circle. The other point that we said was inside the
circle is 7, negative 7. This point down here. Zooming in on this region, we
see that it's just shy of being on the circle. And that should make sense,
because we found that the distance from the origin to this point, was the
square root of 98. Almost the square root of 100, which is 10 to the circle.
And finally, we looked at the point 5, 9. This orange point out here. Zooming
in we see that, yes, it's just outside of our circle.